Bien, como Chris les indicó estudio el cerebro humano,
las funciones y la estructura del cerebro humano.
Y sólo deseo que piensen por un minuto lo que esto abarca.
Aquí tenemos esta masa gelatinosa, kilo y medio de masa gelatinosa
que pueden sostener en la palma de su mano
y que puede contemplar el inmenso espacio interestelar.
Puede contemplar el significado del infinito
y puede contemplarse a sí misma contemplando el significado del infinito.
Y esta peculiar cualidad recursiva que llamamos auto conciencia,
que yo creo que es el Santo Grial de la neurociencia, de la neurología,
y ojalá, algún día, entenderemos cómo funciona.
Bien, entonces ¿cómo estudiamos este órgano misterioso?
Quiero decir, tiene 100 mil millones de células nerviosas,
pequeñas partículas de protoplasma interactuando entre sí
y de esta actividad emerge todo el espectro de habilidades
que conocemos como naturaleza humana y conciencia humana.
¿Cómo ocurre esto?
Bien, hay muchas maneras de abordar las funciones del cerebro humano.
Un enfoque, el que usamos principalmente,
es observar a los pacientes que tienen daño permanente en una pequeña región del cerebro,
que en esa pequeña región hayan tenido un cambio genético.
Lo que sucede entonces no es una reducción generalizada
en todas sus funciones mentales,
así como un atontamiento de las habilidades cognitivas.
Lo que se tiene es una pérdida altamente selectiva de una función
mientras que las otras funciones permanecen intactas.
Y esto nos da la confianza para afirmar que
esa parte del cerebro está involucrada de alguna manera en dirigir esa función.
Con eso podemos mapear las funciones a la estructura
y así descubrir qué está haciendo la circuitería
para generar esa función particular.
Así que eso es lo que estamos tratando de hacer.
Entonces permítanme darles unos ejemplos sorprendentes al respecto.
De hecho, en esta charla les voy a dar tres ejemplos de seis minutos cada uno.
El primer ejemplo es un síndrome extraordinario llamado Mal de Capgras.
Si ven esta primera diapositiva
estos son los lóbulos temporales, los lóbulos frontales, parentales, ¿bien?
los lóbulos que constituyen el cerebro.
Y si miran, oculto dentro de la superficie interna de los lóbulos temporales,
no se puede ver pero ahí está,
ahí hay una pequeña estructura llamada circunvolución fusiforme.
Que ha sido llamada el área de caras del cerebro
porque cuando sufre daños ya no se puede reconocer a las personas por sus caras.
Todavía puedes reconocerlas por sus voces
y decir "ah sí, ese es Joe"
pero al mirar sus caras no puedes saber quién es ¿de acuerdo?
Ni siquiera te puedes reconocer en el espejo.
Quiero decir, sabes que eres tú porque hace gestos
y sabes que es un espejo,
pero en realidad no te reconoces a ti mismo.
Bien. Hoy se sabe bien que el mal se debe al daño en la circunvolución fusiforme.
Pero existe otro síndrome raro, de hecho tan raro
que casi ningún médico e incluso neurólogo ha oído hablar de él.
Se llama el delirio de Capgras
y este paciente que ha sufrido daño en su cabeza
pero que de otro forma seria completamente normal, sale del coma
y parece completamente normal pero mira a su madre
y dice: "Esta se ve exactamente igual a mi mamá, esta mujer
es una impostora,
es otra mujer que pretende ser mi madre."
Así que, ¿por qué pasa esto?
¿Por qué alguien, que es una persona perfectamente lúcida e inteligente
en todos los demás aspectos, pero que cuando ve a su madre
le surge el delirio de decir que no lo es?
Bien, la interpretación más común de esto,
que encuentran en cualquier libro de texto de psiquiatría,
es una visión freudiana y que dice que este muchacho,
y por cierto el mismo argumento se aplica a las mujeres,
aunque sólo hablaré de muchachos.
Cuando uno es un pequeño bebé, un bebé bebé,
se tiene una fuerte atracción sexual hacia la madre.
Este es el llamado complejo de Edipo de Freud.
No estoy diciendo que crea en esto
pero esta es la visión freudiana estándar.
Y entonces cuando creces, la corteza se desarrolla
e inhibe estos impulsos sexuales latentes hacia tu madre.
Gracias a Dios, de lo contrario todos ustedes se excitarían al ver a su madre.
Entonces lo que pasa es que
recibes un golpe en la cabeza que daña la corteza
permitiendo que estos impulsos sexuales latentes emerjan,
que ardan en la superficie y de repente sin explicación
te sientes atraído sexualmente a tu madre.
Y te dices: "Pero por Dios, si es mi madre,
¿cómo es posible que me excite?
Es otra mujer; es una impostora."
Es la única interpretación razonable para tu cerebro dañado.
Esto nunca ha tenido sentido para mí, este argumento.
Es muy ingenioso al igual que todos los argumentos freudianos…
(Risas)
Pero no es muy razonable porque he visto el mismo delirio,
en pacientes que sufren del mismo delirio con su mascota.
(Risas)
Dicen: "Doctor, este no es Fifi, se parece a Fifi,
pero es otro perro." ¿Bien?
Intenten ahora usar la explicación freudiana aquí.
(Risas)
Comenzarán a hablar de la bestialidad latente en
todos los humanos o algo así, lo cual es por supuesto absurdo.
¿Entonces qué está pasando?
Para explicar este curioso trastorno,
observamos a la estructura y a las funciones normales de visión en el cerebro.
Normalmente las señales visuales llegan a los globos oculares
y van hacia las áreas visuales en el cerebro.
De hecho existen 30 áreas en la parte trasera del cerebro relacionadas sólo con la visión
y, después de procesar todo esto, el mensaje llega a una pequeña estructura
llamada circunvolución fusiforme, donde se perciben los rostros.
Aquí están las neuronas que son sensibles a los rostros.
La podemos denominar como el área de las caras del cerebro, ¿de acuerdo?
Anteriormente hablé de esto.
Cuando se daña esta área, se pierde la habilidad de ver caras ¿de acuerdo?
Pero de esta área, el mensaje cae en cascada
hacia la estructura llamada amígdala en el sistema límbico,
que es el centro emocional del cerebro,
y esa estructura llamada amígdala
regula el significado emocional de lo que estamos viendo.
¿Es una presa? ¿Es un depredador? ¿Es una posible pareja?
¿O es algo absolutamente trivial, como una pelusa,
o un trozo de tiza o… no quiero apuntar a eso pero,
o un zapato o algo como eso?¿OK?
Que pueden ignorar por completo.
Entonces, y esto es importante, si se excita a la amígdala
los mensajes caen en cascada al sistema nervioso autónomo.
Sus corazones empiezan a latir rápidamente,
empiezan a sudar para disipar la energía que van a emplear,
generando un esfuerzo muscular.
Y eso es bueno, porque podemos colocar dos electrodos en las palmas de su mano
y medir el cambio de la resistencia cutánea producida por la sudoración.
Así puedo determinar, cuando están mirando algo,
si se excitan o no ¿de acuerdo?
A eso iré en un minuto.
Entonces mi idea fue que cuando este chico mira un objeto, cuando mira
cualquier objeto en realidad, éste llega a las áreas visuales y…
sin embargo, es procesado por la circunvolución fusiforme
y reconoce que es una planta o una mesa
o su madre ¿de acuerdo?
Entonces el mensaje cae en cascada hacia la amígdala
y de ahí hacia abajo al sistema nervioso autónomo.
Pero quizá en este muchacho, la conexión que va de la amígdala al sistema límbico,
al centro emocional del cerebro, se corta por accidente.
Entonces como el fusiforme está intacto,
el muchacho todavía puede reconocer a su madre
y dice: "Ah sí, se parece a mi madre."
Pero como la conexión está cortada en los centros emocionales,
dice: "¿Pero cómo si es mi madre, no siento cariño?"
¿o terror, según el caso? ¿de acuerdo?
(Risas)
Por tanto dice: "¿Cómo explico esta inexplicable falta de emoción?
Esta no es mi madre.
Es una extraña que pretende ser mi madre."
¿Cómo probamos esto?
Bueno, lo que se hace, si ponemos a uno de ustedes aquí enfrente de la pantalla
y le medimos la respuesta cutánea galvánica
y mostramos las imágenes en la pantalla,
puedo medir su sudoración cuando ven un objeto
como una mesa o un paraguas en cuyo caso, por supuesto, no sudan.
Si les muestro la imagen de un león o de un tigre o de una muchacha atractiva empiezan a sudar, ¿correcto?
Y, aunque no lo crean, si les muestro una foto de su madre…
En el caso de la gente normal empiezan a sudar.
Ni siquiera tienen que ser judíos.
(Risas)
Ahora ¿qué pasa? ¿qué pasa si le muestro a este paciente?
Tomo al paciente, le muestro imágenes en la pantalla
y mido su respuesta cutánea galvánica.
Mesas y sillas y pelusa, no pasa nada, igual que con personas normales,
pero cuando le enseño la foto de su madre
la respuesta cutánea galvánica es plana.
No hay una reacción emocional hacia su madre
porque la conexión que va de las áreas visuales a los centros emocionales está rota.
Su visión es normal porque las áreas visuales están normales,
sus emociones son normales -ríe, llora, etc.-
pero la conexión de la visión a las emociones está rota
y por lo tanto sufre del delirio que su madre es una impostora.
Este es un buen ejemplo de la clase de cosas que hacemos;
tomar un síndrome psiquiátrico neural, aparentemente incomprensible y bizarro
y decir que la visión freudiana estándar está equivocada
porque de hecho uno puede llegar a una explicación precisa
en términos de la anatomía neural conocida del cerebro.
Por cierto, si el paciente está ahí
y su mamá le llama de una habitación adjunta, por teléfono,
levanta el teléfono y dice: "Guau, mami ¿cómo estás? ¿dónde estás?"
El delirio no se manifiesta por teléfono.
Si ella se acerca a él una hora después, él dice: "¿Quién es usted?
Se parece mucho a mi madre." ¿OK?
Esto se debe a que existen rutas separadas
que van de los centros auditivos en el cerebro a los centros emocionales
que no fueron cortadas por el accidente.
Esto explica por qué por teléfono él reconoce a su madre sin problemas.
Y cuando la ve en persona dice que es una impostora.
Bien ¿cómo está construida toda esta circuitería en el cerebro?
¿Es la naturaleza, los genes o la nutrición?
Y enfocamos este problema
considerando otro síndrome curioso llamado miembro fantasma.
Todos saben lo que es un miembro fantasma.
Cuando se amputa un brazo o una pierna por gangrena,
o por pérdida en la guerra, por ejemplo, en la guerra de Irak
-que ahora está siendo un problema serio-;
uno continúa sintiendo vívidamente la presencia del brazo perdido
y a eso llamamos brazo fantasma o pierna fantasma.
De hecho, uno puede tener un fantasma de cualquier otra parte del cuerpo.
Aunque no lo crean, incluso de los órganos internos.
He tenido pacientes a las que les retiran el útero, por histerectomía,
que tienen úteros fantasmas, calambres menstruales fantasmas inclusive
en el momento justo del mes.
De hecho, un estudiante me preguntó el otro día,
¿tienen dolores premenstruales fantasmas?
(Risas)
Un tema que espera investigación científica y que aún no hemos seguido.
Bien, ahora la pregunta es:
¿qué podemos aprender de los miembros fantasmas al hacer experimentos?
Una de las cosas que he encontrado es que
cerca de la mitad de los pacientes con miembros fantasmas
afirman que pueden mover los miembros fantasmas.
Su miembro puede tocar a su hermano en el hombro,
contestar el teléfono cuando suena y hacer el gesto de adiós.
Son sensaciones muy vívidas y convincentes.
El paciente no está delirando.
Sabe que su brazo no está ahí
y, sin embargo, para el paciente es una experiencia sensorial convincente.
No obstante, a cerca de la mitad de los pacientes esto no les pasa.
El miembro fantasma, ellos dicen: "Doctor, el miembro está paralizado.
Está fijo en un espasmo cerrado y el dolor es insoportable.
Si tan sólo lo pudiera mover quizás aliviaría el dolor."
Ahora, ¿por qué un miembro fantasma estaría paralizado?
Suena ilógico.
Pero cuando revisamos los expedientes de los casos, lo que encontramos
es que estas personas con los miembros fantasmas paralizados
tenían el brazo original paralizado debido a la herida del nervio periférico,
el nervio que llega al brazo había sido cortado,
digamos que en un accidente de moto.
Entonces el paciente tuvo un brazo real, que le dolía,
en un cabestrillo durante unos meses o un año y entonces
en un intento fallido para terminar con el dolor en el brazo
el cirujano lo amputó
y así obtuvimos un brazo fantasma con los mismos dolores ¿de acuerdo?
Y este es un problema clínico serio.
Los pacientes se deprimen.
Algunos de ellos son impulsados al suicido ¿OK?
Entonces ¿cómo tratar este mal?
Primero, ¿por qué se tiene un miembro fantasma paralizado?
Cuando miré los expedientes encontré que tenían un brazo real,
en que los nervios del brazo habían sido cortados
y que el brazo real había estado paralizado,
que había estado en un cabestrillo durante varios meses antes de la amputación
y que el dolor había continuado en el miembro fantasma.
¿Por qué ocurre esto?
Cuando el brazo estuvo intacto, pero paralizado,
el cerebro enviaba comandos al brazo, la parte delantera del cerebro decía: "Mover"
pero la retroalimentación visual que obtenía decía: "No."
Mover. No. Mover. No. Mover. No.
Y esto se va grabando en la circuitería del cerebro,
es lo que llamamos parálisis adquirida ¿OK?
La mente aprende, debido a la red Hebbiana asociada,
que el simple comando de mover el brazo
crea la sensación de un brazo paralizado
y entonces, cuando le amputan el brazo a uno,
esta parálisis adquirida se traslada a la imagen mental que tiene de su cuerpo
y hacia el miembro fantasma. ¿OK?
Ahora, ¿cómo podemos ayudar a estos pacientes?
¿Cómo desaprender la parálisis adquirida
para poder aliviar este espasmo que aprieta insoportablemente
al brazo fantasma?
Bien, decimos ¿qué tal si uno le envía el comando al fantasma,
dándole retroalimentación visual de que se está obedeciendo su comando?
Quizá se puede aliviar el dolor fantasma, el calambre fantasma.
¿Cómo hacer esto? Bien, con realidad virtual.
Pero eso costaría millones de dólares.
Así que se me ocurrió una manera de hacer esto con tres dólares
pero no le vayan a contar esto a mis patrocinadores financieros.
(Risas)
¿Ok? Lo que uno hace es crear lo que llamo una caja espejo.
Se tiene una caja de cartón con un espejo a la mitad,
y entonces pone uno al fantasma. Llegó mi primer paciente, Derek,
y a él le amputaron el brazo hace 10 años.
Tuvo una avulsión del plexo braquial por la que le cortaron los nervios
y su brazo quedó paralizado en un cabestrillo por un año y después le amputaron el brazo.
Tenía un brazo fantasma con un dolor insoportable y no lo podía mover.
Era un brazo fantasma paralizado.
Entonces vino aquí y le di un espejo como éste, en una caja,
que llamo caja espejo ¿bien?
El paciente pone su brazo fantasma izquierdo,
que está apretado y con espasmos, en el lado izquierdo de la caja
y su mano normal en el lado derecho del espejo
y hace el mismo gesto, el gesto del puño apretado
y mira el espejo ¿y qué experimenta?
Ve que el fantasma está resucitando,
porque está viendo el reflejo del brazo normal en el espejo
y parece como si el fantasma hubiese resucitado.
Entonces le digo: "Ahora mira, menea a tu fantasma,
y mueve tus dedos reales mientras miras el espejo."
Va a tener la impresión visual de que el fantasma se está moviendo, ¿de acuerdo?
Esto es obvio, pero lo asombroso es
cuando el paciente dice: "Dios mío, mi fantasma se está moviendo otra vez
y ya no tengo el dolor del apretamiento."
Y recuerden, mi primer paciente que llegó…
(Aplausos)
Gracias. (Aplausos)
Mi primer paciente que llegó y miró en el espejo,
le dije: "Mira el reflejo de tu fantasma."
Con una risita dice: "Puedo ver a mi fantasma."
No es un estúpido. Sabe que no es real.
Sabe que es un reflejo del espejo,
pero es una experiencia sensorial vívida.
Le dije: "Mueve tu mano normal y la fantasma."
Respondió: "Ah, no puedo mover mi fantasma; usted lo sabe, es doloroso."
Y le dije: "Mueve tu mano normal."
Y dijo: "¡Por Dios, mi fantasma se está moviendo de nuevo, no lo puedo creer!
El dolor ha desaparecido." ¿Ok?
Entonces le dije: "Cierra los ojos."
Y cerró sus ojos.
"Y mueve tu mano normal."
"Ah, nada, otra vez siento apretado."
"Ok, abre los ojos."
"¡Oh Dios mío, oh Dios mío, se mueve otra vez!"
Así que era como un niño en una dulcería.
Entonces dije, OK, esto prueba mi teoría sobre la parálisis adquirida
y el rol crítico de la información visual,
pero no voy a ganar un Premio Nobel
porque logré que un tipo moviera su miembro fantasma.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Si lo piensan, es una habilidad completamente inútil.
(Risas)
Pero entonces me empecé a dar cuenta que quizás otros tipos de parálisis
que uno ve en neurología como los derrames, disfasias focales…
quizás haya un componente adquirido en ellos
que uno pueda superar con el simple uso de un espejo.
Entonces dije: "Mira, Derek"…
en primer lugar, el tipo simplemente no puede andar cargando un espejo para aliviar su dolor...
dije: "Mira, Derek, llévatelo a casa, practica con él por un par de semanas.
Quizás, después de un periodo de práctica,
puedas dejar el espejo, desaprender la parálisis
y empezar a mover tu brazo paralizado
y así aliviarte del dolor.”
Entonces dijo "está bien" y se lo llevó a casa.
Dije: "Mira, después de todo, son sólo dos dólares, llévatelo."
Se lo llevó y dos semanas después me llama
y dice: "Doctor, no me va a creer."
Dije: "¿Qué cosa?"
Dijo: "Se ha ido."
Dije: "¿Qué se ha ido?"
Pensé que quizá se refería a la caja espejo.
(Risas)
Dijo: "No, no, no, usted sabe, ¿este fantasma que he tenido por los últimos 10 años?
Se ha ido."
Quedé preocupado y dije: "Dios mío",
he cambiado la imagen corporal de este muchacho y
¿qué pasa con los temas humanos, éticos y todo eso?
Dije: "Derek, ¿esto te molesta?”
Dijo: "No, en los últimos tres días ya no he tenido un brazo fantasma
con lo cual estoy sin dolor de codo fantasma, sin apretamiento,
sin dolor de antebrazo fantasma, todos los dolores se han ido.
El problema es que todavía tengo los dedos fantasmas colgando del hombro
y su caja no alcanza hasta allá."
(Risas)
“Así que ¿podría cambiar el diseño para ponerlo en mi frente
y así hacer lo mismo y eliminar los dedos fantasmas?"
Pensó que yo era algún tipo de mago.
Ahora, ¿por qué sucede esto?
Porque el cerebro se enfrenta con un conflicto sensorial tremendo.
Recibe mensajes de la visión diciendo que el fantasma está de vuelta.
Por otro lado, no hay una recepción apropiada,
las señales de los músculos dicen que no hay brazo ¿de acuerdo?
Y el comando motor dice que hay un brazo
así que, dado este conflicto, la mente dice: al diablo con esto,
no hay fantasma, no hay brazo ¿correcto?
Pasa por una especie de rechazo, niega las señales.
Cuando el brazo desaparece, la ventaja es que el dolor desaparece,
porque uno no puede tener un dolor perdido flotando por ahí en el espacio.
Esa es la ganancia.
Esta técnica ha sido probada en docenas de pacientes
por otros grupos en Helsinki,
así que puede probar ser valiosa como tratamiento para el dolor fantasma
y, de hecho, hay gente que lo ha probado para rehabilitación de derrames.
Los derrames; normalmente pensamos que son daños a las fibras
y que no podemos hacer nada al respecto.
Pero resulta que algunos componentes de la parálisis por derrame son también parálisis adquirida
así que quizás esos componentes se pueden superar usando espejos.
Esto también ha pasado por pruebas clínicas,
ayudando a muchísimos pacientes.
Bien, ahora permítanme pasar a la tercera parte de mi charla
que trata de otro fenómeno curioso llamado sinestesia.
Fue descubierto por Francis Galton en el siglo XIX.
Era primo de Charles Darwin.
Él indicó que ciertas personas en la población,
que de otra forma serían completamente normales, tenían la siguiente peculiaridad:
cada vez que veían un número tenía un color.
Cinco es azul, siete es amarillo, ocho es verdoso,
nueve es índigo, ¿OK?
Tengan en cuenta que estas personas son completamente normales en otros aspectos.
O un Do. A veces los tonos evocan colores.
Un Do es azul, Fa es verde,
otro tono podría ser amarillo ¿no?
¿Por qué pasa esto?
Esto se llama sinestesia, Galton la llamó sinestesia,
una combinación de los sentidos.
Para nosotros, todos los sentidos son independientes.
En estas personas los sentidos están revueltos.
¿Por qué pasa esto?
Uno de los dos aspectos de este problema resulta ser muy intrigante.
La sinestesia se da en familias,
por lo que Dalton dijo que tenía una base hereditaria, genética.
En segundo lugar, la sinestesia es -y esto nos lleva a mi punto acerca
del tema principal de mi charla, la creatividad-
la sinestesia es ocho veces más común en artistas, poetas, novelistas
y otras personas creativas que en la población en general.
¿Por qué es así?
Voy a contestar esa pregunta.
Que nunca antes ha sido contestada.
OK, ¿qué es la sinestesia? ¿Cuál es su causa?
Bien, existen muchas teorías.
Una es que simplemente están locos.
Esa no es en realidad una teoría científica así que podemos olvidarla.
Otra teoría es que se drogan con acido y mariguana ¿correcto?
Eso puede tener algo de verdad
porque es mucho más común aquí en la zona de San Francisco que en San Diego.
(Risas)
Ok. La tercera teoría es que…
bueno, preguntémonos: ¿qué está ocurriendo en la sinestesia en realidad? ¿bien?
Hemos descubierto que el área del color y el área de los números
están justo al lado en el cerebro, en la circunvolución fusiforme.
Así que dijimos que había algún cable accidentalmente cruzado
entre los colores y los números en el cerebro.
Entonces cada vez que ven un número ven su color correspondiente
y así es como se tiene sinestesia.
Recordemos ahora, ¿por qué pasa esto?
¿Por qué algunas personas tienen los cables cruzados?
¿Recuerdan que dije que se da en las familias?
Eso nos da una pista.
Y esa es que existe un gen anormal,
una mutación en el gen, que ocasiona este cableado cruzado anormal.
Resulta que todos nosotros
nacemos con todo conectado con todo lo demás.
Así que toda región del cerebro está cableada con todas las otras regiones
y éstas se van podando para crear
la arquitectura modular característica del cerebro adulto.
Por tanto si existe un gen que origina este recorte
y si ese gen muta,
se tiene una poda deficiente entre áreas adyacentes en el cerebro,
y si esto es entre número y color, entonces tenemos sinestesia de número-color.
Si es entre nota y color, entonces tenemos sinestesia de nota-color.
Todo bien hasta ahora.
¿Qué sucede si este gen se expresa en cualquier otra parte del cerebro
resultando todas las conexiones cruzadas?
Bueno, pensemos qué tienen en común artistas, novelistas y poetas,
la habilidad de pensar metafóricamente,
de enlazar ideas que en apariencia no están relacionadas
tales como, "este es el Este y Julieta es el Sol."
Bueno, no decimos que Julieta es el Sol
ya que ¿eso significaría que brilla como una bola de fuego?
Quiero decir, los esquizofrénicos piensan así, pero esa es otra historia, ¿no?
La gente normal dice que ella es cálida como el sol,
radiante como el sol, acogedora como el sol.
Se encuentran instantáneamente las relaciones.
Ahora, si asumimos que este enorme cruce de conexiones
y conceptos se produce en distintas partes del cerebro,
entonces esto hace mucho más propenso
el pensamiento metafórico y la creatividad
en personas con sinestesia.
Y, por lo tanto, la incidencia de sinestesia es ocho veces más común
para poetas, artistas y novelistas.
De acuerdo, esta es una visión muy frenológica de la sinestesia.
La última demostración ¿me dan un minuto más?
(Aplausos)
Bien, les voy a mostrar que todos ustedes son sinestésicos y todos niegan serlo.
Aquí tenemos lo que llamo alfabeto marciano, igual que el alfabeto normal,
A es A, B es B, C es C,
distintas formas para distintos fonemas ¿correcto?
Aquí tienen un alfabeto marciano.
Uno de ellos es Kiki y el otro es Buba.
¿Cuál es Kiki y cuál es Buba?
¿Cuántos de ustedes piensan que este es Kiki y ese es Buba? Levanten la mano.
Bueno, aquí hay uno o dos mutantes.
(Risas)
¿Cuántos de ustedes piensan que este es Buba y ese es Kiki? Levanten la mano.
99 por ciento de ustedes.
Ahora, ninguno de ustedes es marciano ¿cómo lo supieron?
Es porque todos ustedes están haciendo un modelo cruzado, una abstracción sinestésica;
es decir, están diciendo que la palabra con inflexiones fuertes, Kiki,
excita los filamentos auditivos en su corteza auditiva,
y Kiki imita la inflexión visual -repentina y cortada- de la forma de las letras.
Esto es muy importante porque lo que esto les está diciendo es que
el cerebro, de manera primitiva, está intentando...
bueno, esto parece una tonta ilusión,
pero estos fotones en los ojos están haciendo esta forma
y los filamentos auditivos en el oído están excitando un patrón auditivo,
y el cerebro es capaz de obtener el común denominador.
Esta es una forma primitiva de abstracción,
y hoy sabemos que esto sucede en la circunvolución fusiforme
porque cuando se daña
estas personas pierden la habilidad de relacionar los Buba o Kiki,
pero también pierden la habilidad de comprender metáforas.
Si le preguntan a este tipo, “¿qué significa "No todo lo que brilla es oro"?
¿Qué quiere decir eso?”
El paciente dice: "Bueno, si es que es metálico y brillante, no significa que sea oro."
Tienen que medir el peso específico ¿de acuerdo?
Así que pierden por completo el significado metafórico.
Está área es ocho veces más grande
para los humanos, que en primates inferiores.
Algo muy interesante está pasando aquí en la circunvolución angular
porque es el cruce entre la audición, la visión y el tacto
y creció enormemente en los humanos, y se está generando algo muy interesante.
Y creo que es la base de muchas habilidades únicas de los humanos
como la abstracción, la metáfora y la creatividad.
Todas estas preguntas que filósofos han estado estudiando por milenios
y que los científicos podemos empezar a explorar generando imágenes del cerebro
y estudiando a los pacientes y haciéndoles las preguntas correctas.
Gracias
(Aplausos)
Perdonen por eso.
(Risas)